hello my name is Mark Johnson and I'm a  governor from the producer Graham is a  graduate film student jean-luc godard  films made a huge impact on me but  equally great was what he and his  contemporaries taught me about what was  right beneath my nose popular American  movies I grew up believing that for a  movie to be important  it had to be foreign or dry or by John  Cassavetes but Godard showed us a whole  generation of us the John Ford Howard  Hawks Alfred Hitchcock and a whole list  of great filmmakers that they were every  bit the artist of everyone else we have  revered from abroad he opened up my  cinematic horizons and introduced me not  only to his own masterful works but  really surprisingly to American cinema  you